Game of Bones is one of the lesser-known and
less understood installments in the Game of
Thrones series.
More than mere pornography, Game of Bones
might actually reveal some deep secrets about
the world of ice and fire.
Game of Bones begins with Varys and Tyrion
immediately breaking the fourth wall.
“They’re making a porn parody, my lord”
“Of Game of Thrones?”
“Yes, and they’re calling it a Game of
Bones”.
Characters in Game of Thrones have never before
exhibited this kind of self-awareness of their
place within a fictional story.
If they know this, what else might they reveal?
One of the great enduring mysteries of the
Game of Thrones show is how Podrick is able
to so impress the prostitutes Marei , Genna
and Kayla that they refuse payment after a
session in Littlefinger’s brothel.
In the first episode of Game of Bones, we
witness Podrick Payne’s prowess first hand,
but we also get a glimpse of something even
more significant.
The identity of the woman Podrick has sex
with is unclear at first.
She does have tattoos – which might suggest
a she’s a Volantene slave of some kind , but
one of the woman’s tattoos looks like a
blue rose.
Blue roses are consistently associated with
Lyanna Stark, the sister of Ned and mother
of Jon, thought dead, but apparently now alive
in disguise as a King’s Landing prostitute.
This could have huge implications for the
story of Thrones – like, how will Jon Snow
react when he finds that his mother is not
only alive, but is fellating Podrick Payne?
These are the kinds of big questions raised
by Game of Bones.
In Episode 3 of Bones, Daenerys Targaryen
meets with Jorah and Daario – Daario looks
like his Season 3 self, and Jorah doesn’t
look much like Jorah at all.
But importantly, we get a glimpse of two of
Dany’s dragons, who strangely look suspiciously
like cats.
Could there be a connection between Dany’s
three dragons and Tommen’s three kittens
– Ser Pounce, Lady Whiskers, and Boots?
We know from a previous video that there is
a wealth of evidence connecting Ser Pounce
to the prophecy of Azor Ahai, the hero prophesied
to save the world, and to wake dragons from
stone.
It’s hard to draw firm conclusions here
but clearly the fate of Westeros is deeply
intertwined with that of Dany’s dragons,
and Tommen’s kittens.
In Episode 4 of Game of Bones, Jon Snow and
Ygritte encounter a white walker, who they
call a “tight walker”.
But the walker is seen holding a white dildo.
As it happens, a white dildo also appears
in Book 5 of Game of Thrones – when Jon
Snow lets wildlings through the Wall, he confiscates
their treasures, including “an ivory phallus”
. How did a white walker get this artefact
if it’s held at Castle Black?
Have the Others infiltrated the Night’s
Watch?
Is Dolorous Edd secretly a white walker?
The evidence suggests probably.
Finally, in Episode 5 of Game of Bones, we
see that King Joffrey has mysteriously become
a woman.
And there is a possible textual explanation
for this.
In Book 4, Maester Aemon says that “Dragons
are neither male nor female … but now one
and now the other, as changeable as flame”.
Dragons change their sex just as Joffrey has
– so the only logical conclusion here is
that Joffrey Baratheon is literally a fire-breathing
dragon.
So in just five episodes, Game of Bones has
shown us greater revelations than we’ve
seen in the last five years of Game of Thrones
books.
Lyanna Stark is alive, dragons are cats, the
white walkers are stealing dildos from the
Night’s Watch, and Joffrey was a dragon
all along.
There is clearly a lot to be learned from
the porn parody Game of Bones.
If you’d like to do your own analysis, you
can watch Bones for free at woodrocket.com,
and that was not a paid promotion, gods save
us all.
There’s a good chance YouTube will demonetize
this video – because violence and war is
okay, but naked bodies and sex are offensive
– so if you enjoyed this dumb video, consider
supporting Alt Shift X on Patreon.
We got some great character and theory analysis
videos coming soon.
Thank you to Patrons duvnull, H Bee, anonyMouse,
and Squidly1.
Cheers.